hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion you might not be familiar with a
little known Chinese car brand called
build your dreams or byd but they sell
more EVS than Tesla from Battery maker
to the biggest electric vehicle or EV
manufacturer in China byd is inching
closer to unseating Tesla as the largest
e maker in the world Chan are you've
seen one and rode in one of its Vehicles
unknowingly their electric shuttle buses
public transport buses trucks and taxis
are cruising through countless cities
globally their influence is expanding
swiftly in Latin America and Southeast
Asia reshaping transportation in those
regions in Australia where I live you
see them everywhere back home in China
they are the number one EV maker and are
now eyeing substantial growth prospects
in Europe interestingly they have a
factory in the US and in 2008 Warren
Buffett chose to invest in them instead
of Tesla
for as little as
$10,000 you can own your own electric
car and that's compelling for a lot of
people but what is the story of this
company are byd cars actually good and
how did they grow to have such a massive
Global presence in this episode we'll
find out to help make sense of all of
this I interviewed Elliot Richards flea
Chargers China correspondent he's got
intimate knowledge of what's happening
on the ground in China I'll include some
Snippets from our chat throughout this
episode
you are watching C Fusion
TV the growing popularity of electric
vehicles is an opportunity for
automakers globally EV designs are
simpler with fewer moving parts and less
complexity this makes the playing field
fresh when compared to combustion
Vehicles Tesla was Far and Away the
biggest player in the space rivan postar
and Lucid were also making names fors
Souls but suddenly out of nowhere in
late 2023 byd came through to knock
Tesla off the number one spot byd likes
to promote itself as the quote biggest
car brand you've never heard of and it's
true at least in the context of sales
figures byd recently overtook Tesla as
the global leader in EV sales Tesla did
its best delivering a whopping 484000
vehicles in the last quarter of 2023 a
solid 11% increase over the previous
quarter but it wasn't enough to keep
their title as the number one EV
manufacturer byd swooped in with sales
reaching 526,000 vehicles for the same
period byd holds an impressive 35%
market share in China their three most
popular models of the Yuan plus the
seagull and the dolphin despite the
whack names they are proving to be a
force to be reckoned with B have been
building cars for 20 years the cars the
last 18 years haven't been very good the
last 3 years really seen a lot of
Chinese Brands focus on I think gimmicks
to be honest with you and I think what
we're seeing now in 2024 is actually a
change into things that people care
about so efficiency the efficiency of an
electric vehicle um you know safety you
know the important kind of Basics
instead of focusing on the the glittery
cherry on top bits I mean what's been
happening in Europe uh the UK and
Australia um is that by are just
offering up their cars and I think
people are surprised at how good they
are these three models cater to
different segments of the market from
sedans and hatchbacks to SUVs while
Tesla's model y secures the fifth spot
as China's bestselling EV it's lonely
out there because it's the sole
representative of American EV efforts
within the top
[Music]
15 byd's EVS have made significant
strides globally too particularly in
Israel and Thailand where they lead EV
sales their electric taxis roam the
streets of Bangkok Indonesia's largest
taxi operator is also planning to buy
80% of its EVS from byd the Chinese
automaker is also expanding into Mexico
Brazil and other Latin American
countries as well as the Middle East in
Europe byd aims to start producing
electric cars by 2025 and they're
currently scouting locations in France
Spain and
Germany now if you're an American you
might be confused and thinking why
haven't I heard heard of these guys well
that's because byd's passenger EVS are
not available in the United States and
it's mostly a political thing China and
the US aren't exactly chummy when it
comes to trade so byd decided to skip
America for their passenger EVS but
that's not all the inflation reduction
act has a strict criteria for federal
tax credits which prioritize us-based
local
production meeting this criteria would
increase the cost for byd as much of its
refinement is based in China
recently Elon even said that Chinese
makers will quote pretty much demolish
most competitors without trade
barriers so all of this is not to say
that byd doesn't have any presence in
the US at all you'll see byd made
non-passenger EVS like trucks buses and
forklifts they also have a 550,000 ft
bus manufacturing facility in California
that employs over 750 workers other
operations can be found in Illinois and
San Francisco where byd has a service
center for its electric buses and trucks
the company also manufactures garbage
trucks distribution Vehicles specialized
tractors for ports and airports and even
a massive 60 ton dump truck used for
mining and this wide range of vehicles
are sold to Global
clients um and then they've also been
able to scale overseas much faster than
anyone else so much so that they're
building their own ships so they've got
uh one container well one roll on
rolloff ship space of 7,000 cars that's
built and they're planning seven more
ships over the next two years or so um
no other automaker has been able to do
that so far so even though you may not
have heard of them you now know that by
is absolutely huge how does a company
get so massive and diversify so quickly
to understand that we need to go back to
the origins of the company and its
founder interestingly the actually a
battery company first and it kind of
makes sense right make the hardest part
yourself and become an expert at that
and then build vehicles around that
company core if you have been following
this channel from the early days you
would know that I've been covering the
rise of electric cars for a lot of years
but I must say over the past few years
things really do seem to be accelerating
I'm excited to say that this week I'll
be in Sydney Australia I'm going to be
taking part in the everything electric
event I'll be doing a special chat on AI
microchips and the electric Revolution
solution with Robert lellan you can come
and see my talk and if you're around I'd
love to say hello to a few of you use
the promo code cold fusion and get 20%
off tickets that just comes to $60 for
all three days entry to the event or $40
for a single day on the 9th of February
which is the day of my talk so if you're
interested in EVs and all the latest in
electric Tech definitely check it out
all the information is in the
description below so thank you for all
of your support and I hopefully see you
there
byd started its Journey as a battery
making company and still is to this day
they make batteries of All Sorts founded
in 1995 by Wang Chuan Fu a former
researcher and assistant professor at
Beijing Technical University byd had a
Grand Vision to revolutionize battery
production in China setting up shop in
shenzen often referred to as China's
Silicon Valley was a wellth thought out
move contrary to what you might think
byd didn't dive head first into EV
batteries its initial product was
rechargeable batteries meant for mobile
phones later they supplied batteries for
laptops and various electronic devices
their client list included major players
like Motorola Nokia and Samsung by 2002
byd had claimed the title as the world's
second largest producer of rechargeable
batteries boasting 25% market share also
that same year the company went public
on Kong Stock Exchange in 2003 Wang
seized an opportunity of a lifetime he
would purchase a struggling company
called chin Chuan investors were rattled
and thought Wang had lost his mind byd's
share price dropped as a result but for
Wang it was a chance to expand his
business and leverage his battery
expertise establishing an R&D Center in
Shanghai he famously had his Engineers
dismantle his Mercedes S-Class and this
was to set the tone for byd's early
strategy
imitate the big boys learn copy and
produce this reverse engineering tactic
paid dividends allowing byd to offer
premium looking cars at affordable
prices initially they mimic Toyota
models but at better value than the
other Chinese competitors but beginning
in 2006 amid a Chinese booming economy
their domestic sales
skyrocketed though at this time they
were mostly gasoline vehicles Wang's
next goal was to create electric
vehicles and the first example arrived
in
2008 this was the same year that Warren
Buffett's birkshire Hathaway purchased
10% of byd's publicly traded shares in
Hong Kong the credit for bringing byd to
Warren Buffett's attention goes to
berkshire's Vice chairman the late great
Charlie
Munga Warren Buffett recalled this
moment vividly in an interview with CNBC
in 2018 quote char called me one day and
says we've got to buy byd this guy runs
it better than Thomas Edison manga
echoed the sentiment comparing W CH Fu
to a blend of Thomas Edison and Jack
Welch a problem solving whiz who may
have taken an idea or two like Edison
and an effective doer like Welch their
initial investment of 232 million in
2008 turned into a jaw-dropping 7.4
billion by 2021 that's a staggering
30-fold or 3,000% gain and that just
showcases the Brilliance of their
investment move it's also a testament to
byd's meteoric growth and success at
first domestically in China and with
Warren Buffett's backing their public
profile increased and so did their
International recognition as of January
2024 byd has a market capitalization of
74.8 billion cementing its position as
the world's 207th most valuable
[Music]
company one of the main reasons for byd
Success was robust support from the
Chinese government as you might guess
China took a serious plunge into EVS in
the early 2000s aiming to shift gears
away from combustion engines the
strategy generous tax breaks and
incentives for both EV makers and buyers
a staggering $30 billion tax exemption
was announced from 2009 to 2022 with an
additional 97 billion in the pipeline
through to 2027 electric vehicle company
tax rates would be slashed from the
standard 25% to 15% and all of this was
enough to get the EV industry
churning throwing in the removal of
license plate restrictions and EVS in
China started absolutely flying off the
showroom
floors for an astute businessman like
Wang it was a golden opportunity he
already had a car manufacturing company
and in-house expertise in making
batteries so the shift towards EVS was a
no-brainer so as demand for EVS grew byd
expanded the range of its EV models and
the Chinese consumers they couldn't get
enough so you might be thinking me this
Wang guy just gets carried by the
Chinese government and that's why he's
successful although there is some truth
to that there is some genuine Innovation
within the company one notable success
story at byd is the creation of the
blade battery a Cobalt free alternative
to traditional lithium iron batteries
this Innovation is touted for its
enhanced safety and stability byd not
only incorporates these batteries into
their own vehicles but also sells them
to other automakers reportedly even
including
Tesla along with the technological Edge
comes vertical integration byd owns the
vast majority of its supply chain for
its EVS from the batteries and motors to
chips and software byd manufactures 75%
of its parts in its Flagship model the
seal for comparison Tesla manufactures
68% of its model y components byd even
has a chip making arm byd semiconductor
which of course makes the chips used in
the EVS this allowed byd to avoid the
global chip shortage that disrupted many
of the other automakers by having its
own battery and Chip production byd can
reduce its costs improve its quality and
can largely innovate faster than its
competitors another reason for byd
success is its price competitiveness the
Tesla Model 3 was supposed to be the
electric car for the Everyman but
starting at around
$35,000 it isn't exactly cheap for that
price the Bas Tesla Model 3 gets you a
range of about 272 Mi on the flip side
the byd seagull starts at about
$10,000 and it offers two battery
options one for 190 Mi and another for
251 Mi these price differences and
feature differences matter especially in
price sensitive markets like China
southeast Asia and Latin America byd's
popularity over Tesla in these markets
are simply because they're
cheaper but how can byd offer its EVS at
such a low price well one reason is
vertical integration as we just
discussed but lower production costs and
economies of scale also help you know
byd have dominated the the battery
Market as well and now they are able to
buy you know lithium minerals in such
volume that they get a really good price
and you know generally in China if you
know you're making a car most of the
materials are from here you know the
labor is a lot cheaper so everything is
just on a on a a cheaper scale so it can
be done uh on a much lower cost which is
why they can produce these amazing cars
for so little
money it's the perfect blend of
affordability and impressive features
that sets byd apart but of course so got
to get to it I know what a lot of you
are thinking if you buy one of these
things the wheels are just going to fall
off when you reach highway speeds while
the cheaper models do leave something to
be desired according to Elliot who is
based in China and has hands-on
experience with these cars they're not
as bad as you first might think yeah
absolutely so something like the seagull
is really a culmination of byd's
expertise and knowledge in all areas so
it's very well engineered the battery
quality the you know battery engineering
is very good and it actually looks quite
good as well now you know byd cars of
the past uh back to about 2015 were
hideous things they looked awful no one
would really want to buy one um but I
think they've come on so much so quickly
that they now can very much be
competitive against things like the Ford
Fiesta or uh the GM you know the Chevy
bolt um those smaller cars and you know
quality really hasn't been an issue with
Chinese made products like this um for
at least five or six years so you think
of you know our iPhones or Android
phones they're all made in China or this
Apple computer that I'm using has been
made in China it's good quality so it's
not a case of you know these products
are now um are poorly made that come
from China because as you can see all
the things we use around us are made in
China so this is basically just
transferred over to things like the byd
SE go but I don't expect it's going to
break or or or or uh fall apart very
quickly there's you know they're all
entering Europe this year and all of the
Chinese cars that are entering Europe
all have Euro endcap five star ratings
um which is not easy to get but they've
all Managed IT so far so I don't think
um it's too much of a concern with these
cheaper EVS byd's Flagship model the
seal is a much more interesting case the
byd seal is a medium-sized sedan with a
Sleek design and overall good
performance it's been labeled as a
genuine threat to the Tesla Model
3 so what's the final verdict on the
seal has the burgeoning Chinese brand
built an electric sportsed air capable
of blasting past Tesla in the sales
race well that's honestly pretty
unlikely given the Head Start Tesla has
but there's really no reason not to
consider the seal if you're looking for
your first electric car well then it is
a pretty compelling proposition
obviously you can make the argument that
it's cheaper and more affordable than a
model 3 but again that is only part of
the story annoying Safety Systems aside
this seal is quick it's quiet it's
Dynamic it's stylish it's comfortable
and it is good value at the end of the
day all things that make it a very
compelling package for an electric
vehicle at this time however it's not
all sunshine and rainbows the vehicle
has been criticized for its overreliance
on touchscreens for functions overly
eager safety assist systems and
confusing and patchy warranty
terms it is clear that while by has made
significant strides in the EV Market
there's still a lot of room for
improvement maybe in a couple of years
we'll all be thinking
[Music]
different despite byd's impressive
growth there were still speed bumps
along the way in 2022 they faced a
hiccup in Australia putting a pause on
the delivery of the byd ATO 3 du to a
child safety seat compliance issue
that's not a small deal another
noteworthy development was that Warren
Buffett who after holding his position
for remarkable 14 years has began to
sell his byd stock in August of 2022
Buffett's birkshire Hathaway has since
reduced his stake in byd by over 60% the
reasons remain undisclosed but anything
from geopolitical factors to a profit
taking strategy could be an explanation
in October of 2023 the European
commission launched an an anti-pr probe
investigation into several listed
Chinese EV manufacturers including byd
the investigation aims to determine
whether punitive tariffs should be
imposed the reason being the protection
of European EV
makers the focus will be on determining
whether Chinese made EVS particularly
those manufactured by byd benefit
unfairly from State subsidies I think
that's a pretty interesting point the
investigation is ongoing and has lasted
for 13 months byd's management has
expressed full cooperation with the EU
investigative authorities so we'll have
to wait and see what
happens um I think to be honest byd are
going to be the new Toyota Toyota for
instance last year sold just
100,000 electric cars byd sold that in
about 3 weeks last year byd uh Toyota
seems set on burying its head in the
sand and ignoring what's happening
around the world whereas B's just taking
hoovering up their
Market in the last decade alone we've
witnessed electric cars explode from
nearly zero to 10.2 million on the road
According to some estimates this number
is expected to grow to 300 million by
2030 the whole EV game is evolving
Chinese companies especially
Trailblazers like byd have been quick to
seize the trend outpacing their Western
counterparts though we cannot ignore the
Chinese government's massive hand on
this but that's just the way it is at
the moment I think it's a fascinating
space to observe so what's your opinion
on this do you think you would ever get
something like a byd are you wary of
Chinese cars or does that not phase you
I'd love to hear your insights so share
your thoughts in the comment section
below anyway that's about it from me my
name is toogo and you've been watching
cold fusion and I'll catch you again
soon for the next episode cheers guys
have a good one
it's you don't take no C
all right I'm going to on my own all
right all
right cold fusion it's new thinking